Ross I believe you wrote a blog post
about how college classmates are future
business contacts and this is something
that you talk to your students about on
a regular basis and maybe you can
absolutely i mean the you know if you're
in film school look to your left look to
your right these are the people you're
going to be working with in your career
and so you want to treat your classmates
well when you should do that just as a
human being but in terms of business
savvy you have to remember that they
have aspirations just like you do and so
not all of them but many of them will
succeed and they'll be gateways for to
help you get a job somewhere they
somebody's going to succeed before you
and then they're going to move on to
their next job and somebody's going to
need to replace them having a good
relationship with them is a good idea I
also tell my students when you go in and
have a meeting with somebody let's say
you get a pitch meeting somewhere or an
interview whatever the situation is be
nice to the receptionist be nice to the
assistance because they're going to be
executives in a few years and they're
going to remember how you treated them
when they weren't quote important and so
it's just been my experience you know
I've been around the business in one way
or another for 40 years now and I still
run into people that I had interactions
with when I was a production assistant
or that at different phases of my career
and it's you can't go wrong being decent
to other people we're in an interesting
time where we're all sort of you know
our own PR company and in some sense
with social media how do we keep up with
our former classmates in a way that's
collaborative without being too much of
a show person yeah what my colleague
Neil Landau who's also a writer and a
teacher and and many of the same things
I am has a really good strategy so to
speak for this where he calls it writing
charming notes and part of the trick of
this is to not have it always be about
yourself if you see that someone that
you've worked with has had a success
write them a note an email a facebook
post or whatever and
say congratulations I'm really happy for
you if all if you're every contact you
have with people ends with and here's
what I want you to do for me I don't
think that's very good networking there
I think if you can genuinely feel good
about your colleagues having successes
there that that's building relationships
over a period of time to and and I think
you have to really say and if nothing
ever comes of that fine you this is
where I get a little from my Berkeley
background into karma and so so on that
if you put good vibes out there then I
think what comes around goes around
you